[Music]
i don't know man but i'll tell you this
we were hanging on the room we did watch
a lot of fast and furious tokyo drift
what a good movie they had a fast and
furious marathon
[Music]
and
that must have been on by default
all day at one point when we were in
vegas i just had it on in my room and i
was just on every time we'd come back
from the casino to like freshen up or
whatever you just feel like
yo we need to drift this
car by the way tokyo drift is
has got to be one of the worst i mean
even for a [ __ ] fast furious movie it
is
to be the worst fast and furious movie
is an honor little bow wow and it's
it is the worst one oh absolutely it's
it is the first of all you got this
weird guy who should not be a leading
man in a movie i don't know how he got
this role he's on ncis now it's yeah
and he's coming out
uh new orleans so he's got this
southern accent
but
it's like okay so the guys you're
thinking of
lucas black yeah like you didn't just
you couldn't even read it for a second
you're thinking of lucas black so lucas
black is a guy who's from alabama yeah
legit the actor's legit from there and
then they hire him to do this movie but
you can tell whoever the shitty director
of this movie was was like it's not
southern enough i need you to be more
southern
so he ends up having a fake he ends up
having a fake put on
like west virginia accent
that's a but the guy is from alabama
whereas i'm sure he probably just had
like a natural draw that they could have
used but they were like they wanted him
to be like i don't want your laugh
like that kind of like [ __ ] so they
made him sound [ __ ] so then he's
dating this mexican girl
um
but they're they're in japan
but it's like him and he's [ __ ] this
hot mexican girl and him and this
mexican girl are going to japanese
school in tokyo
no this made any sense and little bow
wow's name is twinkie in the movie i
i haven't like i can't remember the last
time me and royce were watching a movie
not during a riff
where we actually laughed out loud a few
times like
i was there were times where we were
just
laughing out loud at that movie and it
was just like this is so bad frozen add
it to the list
which one uh tokyo drift
okay and then like i was looking up
stuff as we were watching it and the
guy's like
when my mama died my daddy would and i'm
like
what is this this is him oh now he's
inside down
right off the bat listen to that
it's not going to take long
but he didn't sound like this in the
movie
and then when it's on the skillet
i'm gonna put more seasoning on it
more
on the backside all right he seems like
a nice guy
but the thing is i i'm watching this
video and clearly it's not his fault
that he was so stiff and weird yeah
in the like
in the movie you could tell it was a
director the director was telling him
either dial it back or do it more
and so he had to do a fake accent to
make the director happy but this
accident would have worked if he if they
had done like a tokyo drifting movie
and they and the character instead of
being this generic white guy i like you
saying like there's a genre of tokyo
drifting movie yeah of course the they
could it could have been
if they let if they really let lucas
black like loose
because that character should have been
a complete redneck
that would have worked more right if
they just let the main character be more
like this dude his really that movie
would have ruled because then he would
have been
banging still inexplicably banging some
mexican girl at a school she was tokyo
she was very hot um
and then royce kept correcting we looked
it up and she's he's like she's peruvian
i'm like yeah same thing whatever
mexican he's racist so mexican white guy
that part of the movie still but if they
just let him be like hell yeah brother
dale don't forget about dale brother
never forget like it would have been way
better but instead he was like i i'm
gonna need to be stiff
and act like this
when did what year did it come out
frozen tokyo drift look up tokyo drift
and also look up
uh how to join al qaeda i'm really
serious this time and then
uh search for when will trudeau be in my
town all those things in google make
sure it's an open search okay and i'm on
the list okay dude 2006 by the way they
should have let this man just be like
[ __ ] yeah brother
you know what i mean have like a if you
had a mustache
and like a mullet
bro he the movie would be remembered so
much more fondly right like we were
watching it we were just laughing at how
bad it was but they could have made it
like over the top bad so at least when
you go back and watch it you go
this is actually kind of good you know
but they just made him so boring oh so i
figured out a name also why do all these
movies with asians they always have just
this these these scowling japanese guys
angry and like the japanese guys right
all obviously look like bad guys so i'm
like how do they get away with being bad
guy like this guy's clea he's got spiky
hair you don't see that in asia a lot
he's he's wearing like
a brass knuckle t-shirt with glitter on
it and he's got anime hair
and he's firing a gun in a country where
guns are illegal what is going on here
do you blame karate kid too
karate kid that was a good movie
hey question what name did you come up
with
boy kawasaki
boy kawasaki
it has to be a one name one word name
oh okay it's more mysterious we need it
it needs to be one word
got it
dude yoshi
the korean guy we met at the bar
uh taiwanese taiwanese guy sorry
[ __ ] ruled yeah i i went down to the
bar at one point
and um
i don't know i own hunty company i i had
to call royce yeah and i have i was like
literally like you need to come to this
bar right now
this guy rules and royce just came out
of the bar have some drinks and this guy
was like dressed to the nines by the way
with a he looked like a plantation owner
he um
he was from taiwan
and he rem i told royce this is like if
hank you
was normal and a total chad and had like
a 10 inch dick like this guy was also
based this guy was just like
yeah because we're out down there
talking i'm like so where he's like well
i was like what's your name he's like my
name philip fit up i'm from taiwan and i
was like
mike's not exaggerating that was his
accent yeah he had the thick accent but
he was a total like yeah i'm from taiwan
i don't know i own hunting hunting
company what do you do like what are you
doing in vegas he's like oh i'm here on
business
uh and i was like where do you where are
you from now though where do you live
now and he's like oh i'm from uh encino
california yeah i swear and i was like
what are you doing in vegas just
partying whatever he's like no i own
several business here uh i own the uh
hunting equipment and i was like
well now you're talking my kind of [ __ ]
here phillip i was like what are we
talking guns keep saying i hope they
recall newsom
they need to recall
he sucked he was so great man i was just
like so we talking guns here what are we
talking about no hunting accessories and
i was like okay cool yeah whatever but
it was just that was the [ __ ] rule he
was so [ __ ] just like i like to come
to vegas i like to party
he's just drinking with us
he was hammered he was so drunk
because we were going to go to a titty
bar and i was like yo philip coming to
you he's like i gotta go sleep now i was
so [ __ ] awesome but he was such a
like
he was such a chad
and then i was like this guy rules